hello and welcome to this video
i'm playing kim moovel okay
okay b3a5 is actually not as
trollish as it looks it's actually i
think fairly reasonable
so let's see
i i got some weaknesses here on b4 and
potentially c5 to play against
um what is the best way to use that
probably just a knight f6 and then see
what happens
i was going for another thing keto now
h5 that would be really trollish
not really a fan of that idea
probably d6 e5 yeah like a dark squared
setup
i could just play g6 bishop g7 castles
oh takes that interesting
yeah it takes i guess she takes would
just weaken my structure
a bit too much
hmm interesting
i think i'm still going to i think
cattle this
in some cases such a structure
okay let's do this bishop g7
this is a structure with 92 knight c3 i
can draw
this and so on is generally considered
to be quite okay for white but
here i have the a
file open and the rooks traded that's a
bit different
it's a bit different i'm still not
better or anything it's just
normally white easily gets in b4 b5
which is here
it's not as easy to do
yeah i'm on that square
the very long run i can always claim
that my bishop pair
might do something even though it's um
currently not a factor at all
maybe queen to b6 look at this pawn
yeah i wonder if he's actually
threatening before
but before i take it i would be in a
um yeah pretty annoying pin
hmm i don't know i could play queen to
before
night before knight a4 that's
not a problem really so
i think i can do that
if i would manage bishop d7 rook a8 it
would be nice
get the rook on the open a
file
aha okay so what is the idea knight 84
some kind of
i don't know
right it cannot be bad i think knight a4
queen a5
i mean he doesn't have a discovery with
the knight
at least not a good one that i can see
and after knight a4 queen a5 i'm
actually threatening b5 to
win material
[Music]
i'm still not a huge fan of my position
but
should be okay i feel
maybe what about c5 i can just move the
queen
all right not a move that i expected
i would like to go rook a8 quite clearly
but
this one
[Music]
this queen b6 knight before situation is
really a little bit unnerving
knight a4 queen a5 i still don't see why
this is a problem potentially
queen c1 rook a8
no i don't see why this should be a
problem
so i got this idea
by the way if you look at the videos and
you you check
my ratings you sometimes see rating
jumps
because i'm not covering every single
game i do play games in the
the quarantine league here on the chess
and those i don't
do videos on these are those
arena tournaments and um
for those tournaments we usually have oh
okay
we we play as a team with my club is
playing basically and
we are
during the tournaments we are hooking up
on
on discord and chat a little bit
and so this is not covered in the videos
so it might happen that i gain or lose
rating
between videos it's not that i
skip some games um
it's just uh i'm skipping the whole
tournament so to say
because that's a bit of a different
different uh scenario
right before
[Music]
he's got knight b6 to totally trade
everything off
we might just be happy with the draw
here
i mean not that white has to has any
need to force a draw
it's not worse at all
okay
okay yeah
more or less have to do it
it's it's important to note that this is
increment so i'm not going to
lose on time the 20 seconds
are not really a problem and you could
offer a draw here of course
with black i'm going to
make some more moves but it's it's
largely
i mean it's just not going to
change things unless he's doing
something really stupid
which i don't really see happening
no it's just a draw king h4
and king to h4 and then bishop e1 made
something like that
yeah just take is the draw
i can put the bishop to g3 and
go all the way
to the c pawn but i say it's also just
totally dead
i could simply agree on the draw
but clearly i cannot lose some
and now it just goes back and forth so i
can offer a draw here
yeah that felt like a fairly
correct game in my mind
i am i mean i was never better i believe
and um quite the opposite maybe white
had some pull
so this a5 move i know it looks like
troll chess but it's not so bad um
it delays development but if you get
into a
getting a4 with black you do have some
options on the queen side and
honestly if you if you look at this
let's say that's what we did bishop b2
a4
he plays a pawn move when he has to
develop his bishop somehow
let me play this one and i'm not really
much behind in development and this is a
playable
um playable option so he took there
which was surprising but
it's not terrible
and we got this um this setup
and i thought that it should be okay for
me
but um yeah i don't know i didn't like
it all that much
and around here i felt that there could
be something
and the engine finds i find
it's not so difficult once you get
pointed to it
this idea which is indeed extremely
annoying
now if i move the knight back now um
just grabs this super important pawn
and um yeah c5 is
uh yeah this is not looking good at all
i have a huge hole here on d5 amongst
others
yeah i mean it's it's a little bit
annoying this position
bishop b7 rook a3
and this knight b5 knight b5 is a
motif that i did not have at all on the
agenda
it can do that all the time but it's not
obvious
at least not to me yeah
knight d3 is kind of a way to
yeah more or less play for the draw
let's say or play something super safe
but sincerely i cannot do much
rook a8 feels logical as i'm also a bit
quicker on the a file i think
i probably maybe around here if i'm more
precise
i can maybe pose more problems
taking should be okay but
well yeah yeah it's just it's just not
much
queen c3 maybe i should keep queens on
but
yeah this is i think just equal
and what he did here
this is this is not really very i mean i
try to
somehow keep the game going and it could
be a little bit risky i mean
this is um just making a draw
essentially
but maybe white can try something it
moves like c5
my bishop hair is fairly
yeah unspectacular at the moment and
it's not easy to see how to improve it
and then this is just totally totally
equal yeah not very exciting
but it's what happens sometimes thanks
again
for watching